voilà une polémique qui depuis plus de
dix jours fait grand bruit dans les
médias le cas de la jeune adolescente
milla qui est au coeur d'un vif débat
autour du droit au blasphème c'est dans
un échange tendu avec des internautes
qui l'insultait que la jeune femme se
serait permise dans une série de vidéos
sur instagram de critiquer vivement
l'islam suite à cela de nombreuses
menaces de mort avaient alors été
proférées à l'encontre de la jeune fille
de 16 ans l'empêchant de se rendre à son
lycée et la contraignant à déposer
plainte sur internet face à la violence
de ses détracteurs la jeune femme avait
reçu un soutien massif avec le hashtag
je suis mis là un soutien très vite
contré par le hashtag je ne suis pas mis
là depuis nombreux sont ceux qui se
déchirent autour de la question du droit
au blasphème même au sein de la classe
politique les avis divergent
mais au-delà de ces conflits hier
l'émission quotidien a fait le choix
d'invités en plateau mis là pour
s'exprimer directement sur ce débat qui
dépasse son simple car en soir mais la
bienvenue merci d'être sur le plateau de
quotidiens une adolescente qui se
retrouve une fois de plus exposées dans
l'arène médiatique au coeur d'une
polémique dont l'ampleur est hors de son
contrôle
une affaire qui est devenu un symbole du
débat autour de la laïcité et dont il
est aujourd'hui un déclencheur mais
alors que la france se déchirent autour
de cette polémique pour vous mis là at
elle eu raison de s'exprimer
il a at elle eu raison de s'exprimer
c'est vrai que ça fait énormément parler
puisque tout a commencé par cette vidéo
tournée en direct le samedi 18 janvier
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
gilles non elle a eu tort de s'exprimer
franchement je trouve qu'elle ne
maîtrise pas ses propos les menaces de
mort à son encontre entendons nous bien
sont insupportables insoutenable elle ne
maîtrise pas ses propos l'émission lui
donne la parole n'y a pas de
contradicteur je trouve que yann barthès
n'était pas à la hauteur de la situation
elle s'est exprimée est là elle a
recraché sa haine de certaines d'une
religion elle fait bien attention je
trouve que c'était de la communication
sa mamie extrêmement mal à l'aise saison
elle aurait dû se taire jean michel et
moi je trouve surtout criminelle de
l'avoir invitée sur un plateau de
télévision
c'est quelqu'un qu'on essaie de protéger
qui m attend qu'il cas peu importe les
propos qu'elle a tenus en tout cas ce
qu'est la réalité c'est qu'elle est
menacée de mort au quotidien menacé des
pires sévices
on doit pas l'exposer comme ça la
protéger elle a déjà montré sa tête sur
les réseaux sociaux
j'aurais pas reconnue mais dans la vraie
vie maintenant tout le monde connaît son
vrai visage que là où on la voit vivre
bouger franchement c'est vraiment pas
service à lui avoir rendu que l'avoir
invitée sur le plateau je peux c'est
vraiment dramatique il ya six ans
quelles que soient ses pensées moi j'ai
regardé la séquence
hier parce que je pense que c'était
considéré comme un moment de télé moi je
suis je suis je suis assez déçu par par
la projection médiatique jeu tout à fait
d'accord c'est à dire que il faut
mesurer que cette fille n'aura plus du
tout une vie d'une fille de 16 ans donc
c'est quasiment la mettre sur le sur le
bûcher alors je comprends même pas qu'on
puisse se dire sur un plateau télé qu'on
condamne les menaces de mort enfin je
veux dire un moment quelqu'un qui prend
une position devant trente personnes
c'est quand même l'histoire parle
dollars elles doivent entre autres
personnes
après moi je ne comprends pas qu'on
donne autant d'importance à une fille de
16 ans tu là où elle a été abusée pardon
dire ça malgré le débat de tout à
l'heure c'est qu'en fait des gens
derrière sont beaucoup plus mal
intentionné concernant ce débat que
cette fille de 16 ans qui sont elles se
rencontrent peut-être tard de la
carnation qu'on lui a donné alors que ça
se trouve elle ne veut même pas moi je
te concevoir que enfin hier elle a fait
des erreurs de fille de 16 ans enfin je
veux dire moi si on nous donnait un
micro à 16 ans mais j'aurais dit que de
la merde et moi je comprends pas que
cette fille là aujourd'hui il ya des
gens qui commencent à lui donner enfin
je suis triste pour elle parce qu'il ya
16 ans quand même être l'incarnation du
front national du printemps républicain
les gens qui sont toute l'année mal
intentionnés concernant une religion par
définition et surtout pour conclure là
dessus ça commençait à s'étendre un peu
le fait autour de l'islam c'est à dire
que ça faisait quelques semaines qu'on
en parlait pas à cause des mouvements
sociaux n'étaient plus gilet jaune grève
est en fait grâce à milan ou à cause
d'eux ils ont trouvé un cheval de troie
tout cela on peut discuter et même suis
pas d'accord avec naulleau ou avec
d'autres ici on peut discuter sur le
blasphème ce plutôt favorable en plus
sur le fait qu'on en parle
moi je suis pour que toutes les opinions
existent mais le problème de charlie
hebdo il le faut mais faut pas oublier
que charlie hebdo à la base la promesse
c'est qu'ils sont drôles
on peut trouver pas ça drôle mais jamais
quelqu'un moi je connais de confession
musulmane a dit ben c'est pour ça qu'il
faut aller les buts et dans une
rédaction
à chaque fois qu'il ya de la violence de
toute manière ça juste alors de sa vidéo
depuis sa vidéo polémique sur l'islam il
a subi de nombreuses insultes et menaces
de mort elle explique que sadi a
complètement été chamboulée regarder
ma vie elle est clairement en cause
c'est à dire que ce soit sur ma vie
sociale sur les réseaux sociaux sur ma
scolarité
vous êtes déscolarisés c'est ça oui la
raison bah je suis en sécurité pas en
sécurité dans mon établissement
c'est à dire que si j'ai retourné je vu
les menaces que j'ai reçu des personnes
de mon lycée j'aurais pu être brûlés à
l'acide j'aurais pu me faire frapper
j'ai été menacé d'être déshabiller en
public d'être même enterrée vivante
enfin six parties vraiment moi et donc
vous êtes resté chez vous depuis le 18
janvier dernier
c'est ça après pas forcément je peux pas
en dire plus là dessus alors mise de
l'intérieur christophe castaner annoncé
cet après midi que 1000 avec sa famille
sont sous surveillance policière garde
jeune fille mila dont on a vu que parce
qu'elle usé de son droit fondamental à
la liberté d'expression et à la
possibilité de critiquer une religion
elle s'est retrouvée menacée de façon
très violente pour cela et je voudrais
vous préciser monsieur le député que
mila et sa famille pour l'objet d'une
vigilance particulière pour les protéger
de la part de la police nationale mais
au delà monsieur le député et si ce
sujet ne vous importe peu je tiens la
firme est toutefois ici oui et non
pardon mon parle de millas et sa famille
mais justement parce que j'aurais aimé
c'est que sa famille lui interdisent
d'aller sur le plateau parce que cette
fille là on l'aurait même pas reconnu
dans la rue parce qu'on l'a tellement il
pas sur la vidéo
donc il aurait suffi qu'elle soit
discrète et qu'elle se fasse oublier
plutôt qu'aller se montrer comme ça et à
les vouloir s'exprimer sur des choses
qu'elle ne maîtrise pas elle a 16 ans
elle a fait une grosse connerie et au
final ben allal el en train de remuer le
truc et c'est encore pire je pense éric
on va la victime une première fois des
réseaux une deuxième fois des médias
elle tombe un peu dans tous les sens un
peu dans tous les panneaux la danse
expos qui aurait dû interdire d'y aller
évidemment c'était la dernière chose à
faire humer les cinq tableaux doit
reconnaître quand même que quand le
téléphone sonne que ce soit une émission
comme quotidien ou tpm paix qui
appellent ou les admins et que les gens
pardon dire ça ce soir mais les gens qui
ne vivent pas dans notre système rave
voit ses opportunités d'affairé gens ne
chantent passion de la menace sur la
menace de mort tu combien une invitation
non mais là où on en est
là je suis en accord avec vous ce qui me
surprend c'est que les parents par
contre ne sont pas accompagnés dans le
fait qu'on leur dise mais attention
hier moi ce qui m'a choqué le plus c'est
pas le temps qu'elle fasse une interview
plutôt moyenne faut dire la vérité face
à un interviewer qui l'a accompagné
parce qu'il n'a même pas été dans la
contradiction lui dire c'est pas le fait
de vous n'avez pas pas le droit de le
dire c'est le fait de le dire qu'on sait
que ça peut créer un climat de tension
ce qui me gêne c'est qu'on puisse encore
donner l'opportunité à cette fille de
croire qu'ils allaient chanteuse yelle
annan a quand même est en train de nous
dire qu'ils avaient deux chanteuses mais
j'ai moi je ne connais pas de chanteur
je suis fan de bob dylan
enfin bob dylan serait amusé à dire
avant de sortir son premier album qui
veut mettre un doigt dans le cul dalle
là et aujourd'hui cette nana là il faut
quand même qu'elle redescende ans est en
vérité c'est vrai que c'est assez
bizarre parce que voilà alors on va
revenir sur l'extrait où elle choque
mais elle parle de c2c regret yann
barthès a vraiment insisté auprès de
1000 ha pour savoir c'est le regretté
ses propos polémiques sur l'islam vous
allez voir
elle s'est pas défilée jamais et vous
employer des mots durs insultant est ce
que ces mots vous les regretter
j'aurais pu argumenter j'aurais pu vous
regrettez la vulgarité
je regrette la vulgarité c'est ça vous
dites pas que vous êtes trop jeune pour
vivre tout ça bah si j'aime ce que vous
regrettez quoi je regrette absolument
pas mes propos que c'était vraiment ma
part le droit vous regrettez pas le
droit au blasphème
c'est ça le droit au blasphème alors oui
et on voit que c'est une enfant de 16
ans
mais on voit que c'est une enfant de 16
ans la belle semble penser qu'elle a
bien fait dit en même temps
en même temps c'est la question est très
partagée par rapport à ce que vient de
dire mes camarades parce que je peux
entendre aussi l'idée de dire tout le
monde à parler en mon nom tout le monde
a dit des choses à mon sujet on m'a
instrumentalisé ça me dépasse oui bien
sûr oui peut-être
iovine affirmant j'ai en même temps
peut-être qu'elle avait aussi besoin
elle de dire sa façon d'appréhender ce
qui lui arrive et de d'incarner aussi ce
qui lui arrive de dire c'est pas jusqu'à
ce n'est pas juste un phénomène
quelqu'un sur twitter c'est une vraie
gosse de 16 ans qui s'en prend plein la
tronche voilà bien avec son époque qui
vit avec les réseaux sociaux qui voient
les médias comme une salle culturelle
ans au soudan et en bulles spéculatives
l'extrémisme oui moi pardon je suis pas
choquée sa présence moi je suis prêt je
suis choqué de ces menaces de mort je
suis choqué du fait qu'elle souhaite
déscolarisés exactement le suis choqué
du feuillard l'argent
sur une annonce que ça va on doit être
choqué des deux jérémy non moi je suis
beaucoup plus choqué bien sûr parce que
moi je suis toujours pour le droit duo
blasson je pense qu'on a le droit de
critiquer enfin de blasphémer une
religion et pour moi l'islam pardon
c'est pas une écoute ou une race c'est
une religion de la même année je n'ai
jamais dit géraldine je vis et brillante
parce que j'ai travaillé avec vous la
réalité c'est pas je vais vous dire
quelque chose peut-être vous n'êtes pas
sur ces réseaux sociaux - il s'avère que
je suis sur les réseaux sociaux et que
je pense que les réseaux sociaux ont
rencontré une génération extrêmement
violente
ça c'est du pipi de chat par rapport à
ce qu'on fait monter les cours d'école
aujourd'hui des mômes parce qu'avant ce
qui se passait dans la cour d'école
rester dans la cour d'école
mais quand aujourd'hui vous voyez des
mecs 8,9 mec qui tabassent un mec devant
le collège et qu'il le film et qui après
mettre ça sur les réseaux sociaux on a
affaire à une génération qui doute une
manière n'a pas encore cerné ce qui est
faisable et pas faisable mais yassine
pourquoi celle-ci est menacé de mort et
déscolarisés et pourquoi l'humoriste de
france inter avec son jésus il a su
briller n'est pas menacée de mort alors
je vais vous dire quelque chose je râle
ban
je vous engage à aller sur mon fil
twitter il s'avère que lui aussi il a
été menacé
voilà oui mais juste sous protection
policière il ajouté
non mais moi je suis d'accord pour dire
son on peut le dire dans cette émission
parce que j'aime beaucoup
soit nous les musulmans on a le monopole
des mongols et les autres religions dans
leur extrémisme
non non non pas parce que moi j'ai pas
l'impression que des gens qui balancent
du sang sur des femmes qui sont en train
d'aller se faire avorter c'est pas moins
violent absolument ce qui est le plus
sensationnel il s'avère que c'est des
terroristes musulmans parce qu'ils tuent
des gens qui ça prend de l'ampleur
chaque religion aujourd'hui que ce soit
chez les juifs les chrétiens les
musulmans ou même des gens dans leur
athéisme pousse les gens dans une forme
de folie totale
et pour moi moi cette fille ça me désole
on parle de quelqu'un qui socialement
n'existe plus jean michel ladi
socialement cette fille peut même pas
aller faire des courses ne sais pas
comment elle va se relever de ça mais
vous trouvez que le fait religieux
aujourd'hui iranienne que de la royne en
sont fous de la religion va je m'en fous
de votre religion
vous vous en foutez de la mienne mais
une affaire privée si la sphère intime
est devenu un truc publics ont voyagé
avec eux rien au foot je ne suis pas du
tout d'accord avec valérie géraldine
parce que cette adolescente de 16 ans la
voilà érigé en porte étendard en symbole
d'une cause qui la dépasse total
oui mais habituellement dépasse aller au
bout de votre logique elle n'aurait
jamais dû aller sur les plateaux de
télévision comme pour revendiquer je
vais parler d'une cause en fait c'est ce
qui s'est passé la voilà à son insu
porte-étendard c'est terrible pour elle
il fallait pas y aller jean michel
cousteau pose toi non mais moi je trouve
c'est surtout criminel d'avoir invité on
savait très bien ce qu'elle raconte
répondre et puis elle a essayé de se
défendre quand même elle a dit que
c'était par la critique la religion
qu'elle critique et elle savait très
bien que les gens qui lisent et
sereinement leur religion ici ça c'est
pas les croyants quelques rires mais
c'était la religion d'allah riches
allemands après c'est le jeu des médias
si c'est pas yann barthès qui la reçoit
bien sûr il avoue je pense qu à la base
on est tous aujourd'hui dans une
capacité donc on est quand même devenu
une machine extrêmement violente où on
prend des gens des faits divers on les
médiatise deux mois trois mois et on les
rejette
moi j'ai jamais eu de nouvelles de gens
qui ont créé certaines polémiques j'ai
jamais une nouvelle et pourtant on les a
beaucoup exposé mais gardons dire ça
pour parler de charb paie son âme
il faut arrêter la comparaison l'esprit
charlie l'esprit millar ces deux choses
totalement différentes
je pense que si charb pouvait avait pu
récupérer une vie normale sans garde du
corps c'est ça quand même les enfants
talent j'arrive donc changé c'est le
moment on leur retire leur sécurité
ailleurs dès 2000 est qu un chien non
mais pour aller la droite juste pour
venir sur le plateau ce qui s'est passé
c'est quelqu'un qui dit qu'ils étaient
aussi sur le plateau de quotidiens en
tant que spectateur et je me dois de
réagir suite aux réactions
la régie les techniciens du plateau ont
demandé au public de ne pas applaudir
milla tout au long de son intervention
donc c'est vrai que c'était assez cadré
oui isabelle qu'on attend de moi je
voudrais aussi dénoncé la tortue frites
du milieu parce que j'ai entendu plein
de gens ce matin 10 heures elle aurait
pas dû y aller oui c'était lamentable du
tout et où l'on essayé de la voir
exactement ailleurs on chassait d'accord
isabella temps il va faire appel comme
qui quand il dit je suis d'accord qu'on
des confrères journalistes je veux pas
les balances et se voit je les ai reçus
à la raison il s'ensuit donc ça c'est
pas bien du tout quand elle s'est un peu
trop tôt pour savoir si c'est une très
forte personnalité qui veut jouer la
provoc jusqu'au moulin
une seule question à se poser est ce que
son intervention à quotidien à angers se
situe au nord alors je dis qu'il aurait
aggravé exactement la police n'était pas
la chose je suis d'accord à l'agrément
question pose de sept îles moi je moi ça
m'embête moi je pense qu'elle a été pour
désamorcer un truc là ni si elle a été
ça l'a aggravée mais pouvait pas savoir
à l'avancé une fois de plus à 16 ans il
a dit yassine au départ afin c'est ça
qui me qui me rend fou c'est qu'au
départ a fait un truc avec 30 personnes
ils sont en train de s'insulter des uns
et les autres on l'insulté d'abord on la
soupçonne alors est elle elle répond
c'est un truc qui est intimiste et après
ça arrive à l'assemblée aux femmes je
voulais un truc devait ce truc là il
arrive à l'assemblée
après c'est vrai qu'elle dit le
blasphème moi je suis pas pour les trucs
comme ça de dire enfin si l'as cannes a
dit serein là je suis pas pour je
cautionne pas parce que ça peut rendre
malheureux toute une communauté qui est
discrète et qui fait sa religion
tranquillement sans faire chier personne
et c'est des abrutis qui viennent sur
les réseaux qui fait quand tu fais ta
religion tête quand ils font leur
religion des musulmans ils vont pas sur
les réseaux pour parler avec elle ceux
qui font la religion en paix j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] d'elle ils sont pas sur
les réseaux travers ça c'est comme ils
disent à chaque religion a ses mongols
les mecs ils loi qui nous ont assuré
qu'ils sont élus l'agressé et l'insulté
et l art insultes et derrière c'est une
surenchère
je pensais quand quand elle est venue à
quotidien s'est dit je vais désamorcée
et ça passe a fait les vert et noir ça
nous regarde la violence aujourd'hui de
la cible qu'on appelle les millenium et
maniax 15 34 ans vous parlez des du
lancement de live
oui tu vois les commentaires que ce
régime est si les plus violents sont 15
34 pour pas dire ce que je pense pas
qu'à 34 ya des mecs à 34 ont fait à
manger aux enfants d'en faire c'est des
mecs de 20 ans quand tu vois la violence
d'une critique des fois moi je lis des
trucs sur moi des trucs racistes des
menaces mais je sais j'ai tiré le mec
mais je sais je prends mais je prends
des pseudo non mais faut aussi mais des
fois je vais parce que le mec quand même
au courant de ce qui vient d'écrire ou
ce qu'il ressent ce qu'on n'ait pas fait
en sucre viande truc ça nous fait mal et
compagnie la la nana quand même elle est
très violente
mila pour la cité par dow mais là elle
est très violente parce qu'elle a
affaire à des interlocuteurs quand elle
parle à 30 personnes qui sont tout aussi
violent centrer vers moi j'aurais voulu
vraiment géraldine en toute objectivité
c'est que ça reste mais vraiment un
langage de gamins de 16 à redire niveau
des aldudes se l'approprient il donne
une dimension à cette affaire qui
n'avait pas lieu damian il ya il ya des
gens alors je vous le dis après qu'ils
disent
parce que milla veut devenir chanteuse
lasser je veux pas prise je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui lisent sur les réseaux
aussi qu'ils me la veut devenir
chanteuse et elle s'est peut-être servi
servi de ça ce qu'ils disent face aux
menaces qu'elle a reçus à la crise
chanson intitulée je ne veux pas mourir
regardez est allé au guézy qu'elle sait
peut-être servi de ça qu'elle se sert de
ce buzz qu'elle se sert de ce les
plateaux télé pour peut-être faire un
buzz autour d'elle avant pour pouvoir
peut-être devenir chanteuse alors il ya
région c'est une théorie il allume en
parler dans un instant rien n'est grave
à quelques mots absurdes ils ont détruit
ma vie
elle mais ret
alors de cette voix brisée je chante une
dernière fois pour un blasphème je ne
vivrai plus jamais comme avant
je ne sais même pas si je vais vivre
encore longtemps encore
insultes et menaces mais retournent à
l'école
vite vite scolarisé dans une école
enfin je te dis juste un truc parce que
ça fait longtemps que tu fais ce
métier-là moi ça fait quelques années
aussi pour ceux qui sont dans ce métier
depuis longtemps les gens avant il avait
une envie artistique pas d'accord a
minima
il avait du talent bien sûr il n'est pas
une polémique pour entrer dans le monde
artistique
on est sage aujourd'hui moi je vois des
gens qui veulent faire du cinéma devenir
humoriste devenir chanteur sur une
mauvaise base le être artiste c'est du
travail
et pardon dire ça cette fille là si
aujourd'hui on n'avait pas croisé son ce
fait divers atroce avec tout ce qui
s'est passé mais ça j'en entend j'en
reçois tous les jours moi nation tant
qu'animateur de radio tous les jours
j'ai des petites nanas qui essayent de
chanter sur les histoires d'amour et où
moi je sais pas je me dis vraiment mis
là pour toi je te le dis parce que ta
saison je me permets de te l'assuré faut
peut-être se poser les bonnes questions
au bon moment et je vois pas comment une
carrière peut commencer
alors on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de
retard dans notre métier qui me le dire
mais je vois exactement comment on va
parler toi et compagnie a va se
retrouver dans tous les congrès du front
national en 2022
ça va lui faire tout bizarre est ce que
le front national a repris voilà le truc
alors qu'ils ont des oreilles alors on
va regarder ce qu'il veut sombre et des
spectateurs
oui à 37% non à à 63 pour soi n'a pas eu
raison de s'exprimer
milla moi je pense c'est juste aussi une
ado de saison il faut qu'elle essaie de
reprendre sa vie normale au plus vite et
qu'elle essaie de se faire oublier
si j'étais et j'essayais de me faire
oublier pendant quelques semaines
quelques mois est vraiment qu'elles
reprennent ensuite une vie normale mais
je pense que ce n'était pas une bonne
idée d'aller faire une émission et je
vous dis toute la vérité
on l'avait également demandé sur btp moi
je dis la vérité et voilà et je pense
qu'on aurait relevé gérard his way on a
regretté de l'avoir qu'on aurait
regretté de la reprise parce que je
pense que pour elle ça peut être
dévastateur
voilà d'avoir montré son village de
cette fait autant connaître
voilà et c'est j'espère que ça va
s'arranger pour elle parce que même pour
ses parents ça doit être un enfer qui
vivent au quotidien
c'est juste une jeune fille de 16 ans
qui a dit des mots voilà qui sont pour
moi inadmissible moi je le dis voilà moi
je ne supporte pas aussi écrit dans le
genre de voix ce genre d' insulte comme
comme raymond séduit c'est vrai que
j'aime pas trop qu'on rigole sur les
religions après voilà où on insulte les
religions après c'est vrai que c'est le
droit au blasphème mais en tout cas je
pense qu' il ferait mieux de se calmer
et de rester dans son coin pour que tous
c'est votre nom la route